tonight it's my pleasure to present the
award to the composers and lyricists who
write our songs
jessalynn tation might have forgotten
Charlie Chaplin is also a composer too
mr. Chaplin I say with deepest respect
feel common Bienvenue welcome as I'm
sure to all the writers whose songs have
been nominated tonight the nominations
for the best song are the age of not
believing music and lyrics by Richard M
Sherman and Robert be sure all his
children music by Henry Mancini lyrics
by Allen and Marilyn Bergman bless the
beasts and the children music and lyrics
by Barry Devore's on and Perry Botkin
junior life is what you make it music by
Marvin Hamlisch
lyrics by Johnny Mercer theme from shaft
music and lyrics by Isaac Hayes and the
winner is Isaac Hayes thinking
again they said make it short everybody
was involved and motion picture I thank
you I'd like to thank the Academy and I
would like to thank the Stax
organization for encouraging me to
school motion picture most of all I'd
like to thank the lady who's here with
me tonight because years ago her pet
prayers kept my feet paths of
righteousness and that's my grandmother
and this is a thrill for me and also a
few days her 80th birthday and I this is
her present